>> Peter Vankevich: OK, folks.
If everyone wants to sit down
and we'll continue our show.
And our big introducer
is Mandalit del Barco,
and you're with NPR out in LA.
So that's -- welcome,
by the way.
[ Applause ]
And Luis. All right.
Go ahead. Thank you.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
Thank you so much.
Can you hear me?
Yes, OK. Thank you so much
for inviting me to talk
with this amazing author.
As he explained, I'm with NPR.
I'm an arts correspondent.
And so I get to read
a lot of books.
And it's such a pleasure
to read books by an author
that I really love that
we're going to talk to today.
And if there's time,
we're going to open
up to questions from you, too.
So just to get started, you
know, NPR has called our guest,
Luis Alberto Urrea,
a literary badass.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Do
you get that all the time?
[ Laughter ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
I've been hearing it, yeah.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah,
that's pretty cool, I think.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Alan Cheuse.
You can't argue with him.
>> Mandalit del Barco: So
he is an English professor
at the University of
Illinois in Chicago.
And he's written in
many, many genres.
Fiction and nonfiction, poetry,
short stories, and five novels
that include Into the Beautiful
North, The Devil's Highway --
which was nominated for a
Pulitzer, congratulations --
the Hummingbird's Daughter,
the Tijuana Book of the Dead,
and his latest is
House of Broken Angels,
which we'll be hearing
about more today.
Now this book is a sprawling
family saga that takes place
in San Diego where
you grew up, right?
And I understand it started off
as a tribute to your brother --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Right.
>> Mandalit del Barco: -- Juan.
He died three years ago?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Three years ago.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
I'm sorry to hear that.
But it has inspired
this amazing book.
And in this book, as you
write -- well, in the book,
the character, Big Angel
-- or do you say Big Angel?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
No, Big Angel.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
Big Angel.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
>> Mandalit del Barco:
Aha, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Chicano.
[Speaking Spanish]
[ Laughter ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Well, in
the book, he's dying of cancer,
and his mother died
at the same time --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Right.
>> Mandalit del Barco: -- or
almost around the same time.
Can you start off by
describing Big Angel
and Juan, your brother?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Juan.
How do I put -- I
was born in Tijuana.
We come from Colonia in
the pendenza in Tijuana.
Spanish was my first language.
My dad was Mexican,
my mom was American
from Staten Island, a socialite.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Ah.
[ Laughter ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
My dad was the first
Mexican she ever met.
[ Laughter ]
But he was a guerito.
He was the white one.
I mean, she was obviously
a white woman,
but my dad was red-haired,
blue-eyed,
looked like Errol
Flynn, you know.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Or thought he did.
[ Laughter ]
And [speaking Spanish], my dad.
So he had other families, right?
>> Mandalit del Barco: Hm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
I had siblings,
but they weren't,
you know, in my home.
And so Juan was the big
brother of that crew.
And they were still in Tijuana,
and we left Tijuana and moved
to San Diego because my mom
wanted to be back in the USA.
I was quite ill.
Our barrio was annihilated
by tuberculosis, so --
and my dad, he had a green card.
Don't be thinking
bad thoughts, now.
But he had a green card.
And Juan was in Tijuana, and he
never let go of his grip on me,
even though I was gone.
He believed in me.
And I don't know that I
believed there was any hope
for me whatsoever.
I came out of this
hopeless world, right?
But Juan loved to read, and
he loved to read English.
And one thing that -- I put it
in the book, but it's true --
my dad instigated
learning Ingles
by memorizing the dictionary.
So he memorized five pages
of dictionary a week.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
And he used to have these
contests with Juan, right?
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
And they would sit there
and battle out English.
And my task was to give
my father English lessons,
which is not really fun
if you have a grouchy
Mexican dad, right?
[ Laughter ]
And he was always
smoking Pall Malls.
And I talk in the book about
how old Mexican folks love
instant coffee.
My dad was an instant
coffee addict,
so I grew up with the sound of
the spoon: tinky-de, tinky-de,
tinky-de, tinky-de, tinky.
So he'd make one, and he'd say,
andale, [speaking Spanish].
And I'd say, ay, Papa.
What do you want to know?
Ask me any question
about English, go on!
In the As.
[ Laughter ]
And I'd be like, OK,
Dad, what's an aardvark?
And he'd be like, jeez!
[ Laughter ]
You know, with that cigarette.
And he'd say, un aardvark --
un aardvark is an animal with
a big, long nose, he eats ants.
I'd say, good, Dad,
you passed, right?
[ Laughter ]
So he and Juan would
do this combat.
And Juan felt that it was a
great triumph for a Mexican
to read books in English.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Hm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: And
he loved science fiction.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Me, too.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Right?
>> Mandalit del Barco: Oh, yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh, yeah?
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: That
was my thing when I was a kid.
So he would send with
my dad books to me.
And that's how I discovered
Ray Bradbury, through Juan.
So in some ways, you could
draw a direct line maybe
through Ray Bradbury to
me because of these books.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
So Juan got ill.
My father had been long dead.
Juan got ill, and he had
this impending death.
It was fairly clear
he was going to die.
And his mother -- not
my mom, but his mom,
was about to have
her 100th birthday.
And so the family thought, what
if -- because her birthday was,
like, a week before -- or
a couple weeks before his.
But they were like, what if
we get all the family together
to give him a farewell
birthday party,
knowing it was going
to be adios, right?
And my brother, what you
need to know about him,
he was a very willful
man and pretty sure
of his own impressive nature;
in other words, an egomaniac.
So when he heard
that they were going
to throw him a goodbye
birthday party, he was like, oh,
I can have my own
wake and attend it?
[ Laughter ]
Right? I can plan my own wake
and then receive all the --
you know, before I die,
told how great I am.
So that was in play, and his
mother died the week before
his party.
And, boy, was he mad.
[ Laughter ]
He was, like, ay, ma.
You know, of all
the times to die.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Upstaged.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yeah!
>> Mandalit del Barco: Ah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
It's like,
I was going to have a party.
So he being the patriarch
took over her funeral.
And she had her funeral
on Saturday,
and then he had his
goodbye party on Sunday.
And my wife and I, of course,
and our daughter
went to this thing.
And I had never seen
anything like it.
I often say this -- you'll
know this with LA experience.
But every kind of
Mexican you ever imagined
and some you didn't
were all there at once.
Every generation.
There were the abuelitas,
you know,
and there were gang
bangers, you know,
there were vatos,
all the cholos.
There were the PhD crew
and the professionals.
And then all the sudden this
group of Samoans went through.
I was like --
[ Laughter ]
-- I said, who's the Samoans?
They're like, that's
your cousins!
I was like, oh, primos!
[ Laughter ]
It was neat.
And there was this
mad thing going on.
And I'm watching my
brother, who's clearly dying,
and that was what inspired
the book, just realizing --
I didn't know really --
we called it the
Mexican-Finnegans Wake.
We didn't really know -- I
didn't know that it was a book,
but Cindy, my wife, kept saying,
you've got to write about this.
And I said, what's there to
write about burying an old guy?
There's no story.
And she'd say, really [laughs]?
[ Laughter ]
And I realized, you
know, the story was
in the layers and
the generations.
And I thought, I've written
so many border books.
And I thought, in some ways this
is my farewell to the border.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
You know, I've done it --
I've done it 25 years
preaching the same gospel,
and it's still bad.
There's still 500 children
stuck in a cage somewhere.
And I just thought, I don't
know how much I can say this.
But I thought maybe I can talk
about the depth of the soul
of this family, people who are
Americans by any definition --
even the current
definitions, maybe.
They've been here 70 years --
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: -- gone
to school, vote, paid taxes.
But they're Mexicanos.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Exactly.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
And how do you then deal
with being an American and
trying to bury your dad
and having somebody
come up to you and say,
the president's going to
throw you out of this country.
And I thought, if I can drop
those shocks in the book,
maybe my readers will
understand what it feels
like when somebody goes after
you out of the blue, right?
So there were all
those things going on.
And I wanted to show readers I
had finally become, you know,
a mature adult and
wasn't doctoring error,
so I made Big Angel
a Republican.
I thought, it isn't my first
Republican hero, you know.
[ Laughter ]
So that they can't accuse me of
being too liberal or whatever.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Well,
speaking of that, I mean,
we are now in Washington, D.C.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Hm!
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm,
not too far from
the White House.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Hm!
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
And I don't know what --
and with this book and even
just here on this stage,
what would you like to
tell President Trump
and the politicians here...
[ Hard Coughing ]
[ Laughter ]
It's an invitation
to say what you feel.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh, boy.
Mi horno.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
Mi horno [laughs].
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
You know, honestly,
I don't even know what to say.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: When
we were driving in yesterday,
you know, I do stuff
with the NEA,
and we went by the
old post office.
And I thought, you know,
we authors used to sit
on the steps in front of there.
And it just was so weird what --
you know, it's a foolish thing
to say, I wish you'd
read my book.
I did a pretty good
audiobook, just listen to it
and maybe it'll soften
your heart a little bit.
But I'm not sure the hearts
right now can be softened.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: And I
don't really understand it.
I don't know why us.
One of the tings I do with the
NEA is talk to lots of kids.
And I can't tell you how
hurt and afraid and wounded
and self-loathing a lot
of our children are now.
And I keep trying to tell them,
it's going to be OK, you know.
Kids like to laugh, right?
So I tell them, look,
this whole thing,
it's like a lighthouse
that's casting a beam
of hating somebody else around.
And it used to be Irish people,
it used to be Chinese
people, it was Germans.
Sometimes I read them what Ben
Franklin said about Germans.
It sounds just like what's
being said about us now.
And I tell them, you
just got to believe me.
This is your century.
You guys are going to be fine.
And they'll get bored with
you, and they're going
to get really pissed off
a Norwegians one day.
[ Laughter ]
And then you're going to
hear, like, stop the Vikings!
[ Laughter ]
Build a wall up the East
Coast and stop those Vikings!
You have to prevail
and hold steady.
But, you know, if
we're not, I think,
out there actively giving
love and hope to people,
I think we're doing
a bad, bad thing.
So I don't know what I'd say.
I really don't.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Well, you
talked about having this career
of writing about the border.
And I know that you grew
up right along the border.
Tijuana and San Diego, if
you've never been there --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Ha!
>> Mandalit del Barco: --
it's very different places.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
It's different.
>> Mandalit del Barco: And
I remember being there --
I mean, I've been
there since then,
but it's -- starting in 1990.
And I remember on the Tijuana
side, it was like a carnival.
People selling, you know --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yeah.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
-- popsicles --
older women, babies,
just -- it was like a --
I don't know, it
was so different.
And you could walk through
a hole in the fence.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Yes [laughs]!
>> Mandalit del Barco:
And that's not the case --
I mean, I did that
actually once for a story.
But that's another story.
But growing up in that back in
the day, can you talk about how
that border was before and how
it changed, and what it was
like for you growing up with
that border symbolically
and physically with the borders?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Well,
it was never laugh riot
necessarily, the border.
But back when I was a kid,
the border was certainly
not what it is now [laughs].
It was incredibly funky.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: And
you would drive actually
through the Tijuana
River, which is,
you know sewage effluent,
basically.
But it was all wooden bridges.
And the Mexican guys
couldn't care less.
They never looked in.
They're like, yeah,
just go on through.
And when you'd come back to
the US -- I put it in my book.
But when you come
back to the US,
there were about
six plywood booths
with really bored US
officials sitting in there.
And there were no
computers, there were no,
you know, no cell phones.
They had a booth, maybe a
fan, if they were lucky.
They had a typewritten list of
gangster license plates they had
to watch for each
car pulling up,
and they had a dial phone
in case they saw one.
Get down here.
[ Laughter ]
And there was this
whole little ritual.
You'd pull up to the booth,
and the guy would get out,
and he'd say, hola, amigo
[speaking broken Spanish]!
[ Laughter ]
And the guy would
hold up a green card.
Oh, that's good, amigo.
And then they would give
you this entrance exam.
They would say, amigo,
tienes usted liquor
in la trunko del carro?
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, every single
Mexican would say, no, senor --
the trunk full of liquor.
[ Laughter ]
No, not me [inaudible].
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
And that was it.
And I loved Tijuana because
I thought Tijuana was --
you know, that's where
everybody that I loved lived.
That's where the
best tortillas were.
That's where all the dogs were
running around, and my grandma,
my aunts and my cousins,
and the music everywhere.
And I loved Christmas
in Tijuana.
And then we moved.
And then we were in the barrio
right on, you know, the US side.
And that was really odd
because it was instant race war.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Brown versus white
versus black, right?
And there were not
a lot of white folks
in that neighborhood,
but there it went.
And I was talking Tijuana, man.
I had this accent when
I came out of Tijuana
because I was still
learning English, Chavez!
And I was talking
Spanglish, right?
So how a bike was una
bika [phonetic], right?
Somebody's wife was
la wifa [phonetic].
And then cake was
cakee [phonetic].
Except it was an old lady,
and she'd put a diminutive,
so she'd say un cakeecito
[phonetic].
[ Laughter ]
That's how I was talking.
So you could imagine me walking
through the race
war neighborhood.
Irish looking dude
talking all Tijuana.
And it was like,
you know, all --
it was like, peace right
through the barrio.
Because everybody's like,
gentlemen, let us kick his ass.
[ Laughter ]
And then in fifth grade, I moved
up to a little working-class
suburb to the north.
My mom was in heaven,
right, because she was back
to white folks and heaven.
And I found out in fifth
grade that they hated us.
I had never been more
shocked in my life.
And, you know, I lost my Mexican
accent [snaps] like that.
I think -- I didn't
mean to, but I thought,
I'm not going to survive here.
All these nice kids, you know.
I've talked about
this on stage before,
but I thought I'd
gone to heaven.
These guys had lawns,
green lawns.
I thought, wow.
And they had the Boy Scouts.
I was like, well, that's the
coolest thing I ever heard of,
right?
We'd dress up in little
uniforms and go camping.
But my dad had been a
Mexican military man --
macho -- and he hated it.
He hated it.
He didn't approve of
the Boy Scouts at all.
And I remember coming home
one day after a campout,
and I was in my little
uniform, and he's like, mijo,
you're wearing shorts.
I said, yeah, it's our uniform.
He said, it's got knee socks.
I said, yeah, it's
our uniform, Dad.
And he said, mijo, if you want
to be a man, join the Army.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Whoa.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: I was
like, I'm in fifth grade, Dad!
[ Laughter ]
You know...like...and
that's when it hit,
like, during that period.
That's when -- you know, you
hang out with your homeboys
and you're in the
bathroom, fifth grade.
All my new white boy
friends, you know?
And they didn't know
how to say my name,
so they thought my
name was diarrhea.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
Oh, my God.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Urine.
Urethra. And unreal.
And unreal, I thought
that was pretty cool.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
That's cool, yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
And we're in the bathroom,
and one of the boys from my Boy
Scout troop says, hey, Unreal,
you know what you are?
And I said, no what am I?
And he said, you're a
greaser wetback, man.
And they all started
laughing at me and yelling,
greaser, greaser, greaser!
And I remember just
standing there thinking,
que que, what is that?
And they all left, and they
left me in the bathroom alone.
And I started looking
for the grease.
Like, in that moment,
I thought we have --
we are drooling grease
and don't know it and all
of you all are looking at us
saying [scoffing], disgusting.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
And that's when it turned.
That's when I started
hearing things against us
and that -- it was filthy.
And that, you know, people
in Mexico smoke horse
dung cigarettes,
and all the women
are prostitutes,
and they eat cat tacos.
I thought, what?
So I was lost.
I didn't know what to do.
And that was kind of
my journey into the US.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Well,
and a lot of this you have
put in your books, too.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh, yeah!
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
It's revenge!
>> Mandalit del Barco: That
is a great revenge, yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: No.
But, you know, people
are going through this.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
Still.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Still.
And it's not just Latino people.
People are going
through this stuff.
Asian people, African
American people.
It doesn't cease, and so
you just want it to cease.
I never understood what
is the problem of looking
at somebody and loving them.
It's really hard, right?
They're just a person.
They have babies, they
have dreams, they're tired
at the end of the day.
Their feet hurt.
What's the problem?
I've never gotten it.
And I really didn't get
it in that neighborhood,
and then I didn't get it
in my [laughs] later,
better neighborhood.
And so I've always sort
of insisted on trying
to represent that culture.
And I've got to say, the
border -- you know, the border,
to me, it's just a metaphor.
It's a physical metaphor.
Because the border's
running right
through every audience
I ever see.
Things separate us
from each other.
You know, being a teacher, you
see a group of young women come
into class wearing the hijab.
Other students move
away from them.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: So my job
is to make the other students...
>> Mandalit del Barco:
What do you say to them?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
It doesn't take long
because they're very
smart young women.
So we come early, and I
always start the class saying,
as-salamu alaykum, they
say, alaykumu as-salam.
I say, hey, how's your dad?
Oh, my dad's hilarious,
my dad --
because everybody in the
class is thinking, oh,
their dad's...terrible men.
No, I love -- my dad's so funny,
blah, blah, blah, you know.
How's your boyfriend?
Oh...you see that movie?
Just to watch other kids watch
us interact and start to think,
well, this is interesting,
I've made a discovery,
these folks are human [laughs].
I think we're all just
waiting to discover
that everybody else is human.
So that works.
It's a really wonderful thing.
You can see the class
come together.
You know, last year, I had
some of my favorite students
of all time, Muslim students,
that were in my class.
And we were studying things
like Hunter S. Thompson.
And I told them -- I would
give them a heads up each book,
Jack Kerouac, what he's like.
But when Hunter S. Thompson
came up, Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas, I said, this book,
100 percent harem,
bad, bad, bad.
I just want you to know.
They're like, we can take
it, you know, we can take it.
[ Laughter ]
So they read it.
And spring break was coming.
And then young man -- I said,
what are you doing
for spring break?
He said, I'm going
to Cabo San Lucas.
And I said, wait a minute, that
is also 100 percent harem, man.
I said, what are you going
to do about drinking?
He said, I am not
going to drink.
And I said, what about
all the naked people?
He said, I'm going to look.
[ Laughter ]
You know, if -- I don't know.
If people can see you laughing
with somebody or crying
with somebody, what
are they going to do?
How can they possibly walk
away from that table and say,
psh, those people, right?
>> Mandalit del Barco: Right.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: So
that's what I try to do.
>> Mandalit del Barco: So do
you think that you're going
to continue writing
about the border?
You said you've done
it for so long,
are you just going
to -- is it --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
I can't stop.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
I can't stop.
And when this book came
out, I mean, this --
there were so many
transformative things
for me in doing this book.
I've never suffered
so much for a book.
I just cried and cried,
you know, writing it,
envisioning my brother in his
demise and those tender moments
between us at the end.
But I was really afraid because
I thought, oh, man, you know,
I've written this
picturesque novel
and clearly some characters
are based on family members,
and they are going to
give me such a rough time,
and they're going to be
offended and all this stuff.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
And did they?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Well...
[ Laughter ]
The book tour -- this is the
first time I've had a book
that's hit, like, an
avalanche in my life, you know.
And we were on tour.
I always go with my wife because
I just can't take it anymore,
so we do it together.
But yeah, we went
back to San Diego,
and there were 300 people jammed
in the book store [laughs].
And there were people outside
looking through the windows.
And my family was there.
And they all go their
old suits, you know,
and they sat in the front row.
And it was really cute
because as I was reading,
they were holding my book up,
like I didn't know
I'd written it.
[ Laughter ]
Right? And my brother named
Octavio [assumed spelling],
he's another kind of a Lothario,
you know, another playboy,
and he always has
new girlfriends.
And he was sitting there
with this really
befuddled looking woman.
And my whole reading, he's
pointing to her saying,
my girlfriend, that's
my girlfriend.
[ Laughter ]
So after it was done,
the family came up to me.
And I have a nephew who
is very much the model
for Lalo [assumed spelling]
in the book, the crazy boy.
And I thought, oh,
what's Juanito [assumed
spelling] going
to think, you know.
And he came up to me and he
was looking around the store
and he said, Tio,
you've made thousands
of people love my family.
Oh! Right?
Next thing he says
[snaps] this quick is,
so who's playing me
in the movie, dog?
[ Laughter ]
And I said, that's not you.
And he said, yeah, it is.
[ Laughter ]
So it's really cool that you can
do that and fear their response
but have it be a gift to them.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
So would you --
so who would play in the movie?
[ Laughter ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
I don't know.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
Who would you cast?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: It's got
to be a wild man to play Lalo.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
That'd be fun.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
We've sold it, you know.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
We've sold it to Hollywood.
Yeah, I think it
may be a series.
We don't know yet.
It'd be better as a series --
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: --
like, on Netflix or something
so that -- you know,
the producer wants
to do ten episodes so that
he can get deeply into all
of the stories and not rush
it through a two-hour film.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Would
you want to be involved in,
like, all those decisions?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I think I might get
a hand in writing some
of them, so that's good.
>> Mandalit del Barco: And what
about -- who would play you?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Me?
>> Mandalit del Barco: Yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
It ain't me.
That's Little Angel.
[ Laughter ]
But my experience
informs his experience.
But, you know, who
would play me?
I don't know.
Oh, you know, Lin Manuel,
somebody like that.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Ah.
There you go.
You know, in the book,
Big Angel has a notebook
and he writes all the things
that he's grateful for.
Do you have a notebook, or do --
what are some of the
things you're grateful for?
[ Laughter ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Look!
I mean, every time I see an
audience, especially like this,
I think, dude, you were
up at 3 a.m. on the floor
of your bedroom in
your boxers listening
to Leonard Cohen writing
really bad poems in a notebook.
And now look!
[ Laughter ]
So I'm really grateful.
You know, I'm grateful
for a lot of things.
I can't believe that I've
been given this blessing.
I can't believe that
somebody like me
who can't write a good
plot and can't figure
out a good commercial book
[laughs] has kept publishing
books and had so many
people read them.
You know, after so many
disastrous relationships
in my family to have a,
you know, a great marriage
and happy, healthy kids.
Our last daughter just
went off to college.
I can't believe that.
So I'm grateful for
so many things, yeah.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
I'm wondering,
I heard that Ursula Le
Guin helped you out.
What did she do?
How did she -- in
your writing career?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
How're we doing for time?
>> Mandalit del Barco:
We have...
[laughs].
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Ursula Le Guin.
I was the first -- I think I
mentioned, I think, earlier --
the first one in the
family to go to college.
And though my mother and father
were separated by then --
because he could not
control his player ways.
He got caught, you know,
was sent packing by my mom.
But he was so proud that I was
going to college that he went
to Mexico to get money.
He'd been sending --
we know this story.
He'd been sending money home
from his jobs for years.
And he went back to Sinaloa, 27
hours, and he got $1,000 for me.
And he drove back alone
27 hours and then crashed.
And there's a lot
of implications
that really evil border
Mexican cops were involved
in that crash.
And they had him, and he died
in their care after eight hours.
And they sold me the corpse.
They wouldn't let me bury
him, they made me buy him.
And I was, you know, 19, 20,
something like that,
and -- maybe 21.
And I wasn't prepared.
I didn't -- and I
was in college,
and it was my senior year.
And I had already
wanted to be a writer
and I was doing writing
workshops.
And they had brought Le Guin
in as a visiting scholar.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: And my
favorite English professor --
all I knew how to do
was write about it.
And I wrote a piece about
it, and he took it to her.
And she immediately accepted
me into her workshop,
which was a big surprise to me.
And then she took
it for publication.
It was my first sale.
And she took on the
job of coaching me
in how to be a writer.
She taught me manuscript format.
I didn't know anything.
You know, she told me --
you know, she used to call me
Luisito [assumed spelling].
You know, Luisito, you have
to actually type these things.
You can't just print
them out on blind paper.
But I didn't have a
typewriter, I was too poor.
You know, and she guided
me through so many things.
She was so cool.
This was long enough ago
that I got to take her
to the first time
she saw Star Wars.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: How
cool -- and she was tiny.
And back then, she
used to smoke a pipe,
which I thought was really hip.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Oh.
[ Laughter ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: And she
drank whiskey in a square glass.
I thought, this woman's,
like, the coolest person.
[ Laughter ]
And she would sit
sideways in the seat.
Like, if you went to the
movies, she was so small,
she could sit sideways
in the seat.
And she was leaning over
and explaining the science
errors in the movie.
[ Laughter ]
Which I didn't know
at the time was going
to be a cherished thing.
And she was the one who was
like, you're very much a boy.
You know, it's time for you
to get into some feminism.
I'd say, OK, whatever you say.
You know, she guided
me and scolded me.
And she used to call herself my
Tia Osa, my Aunt the She Bear.
You know, so she
was always around,
and she taught me
a lot of stuff.
She once said to me that, you
know, writers are the raw nerve
of the universe; that everybody
out there's forgotten
what it means to be human,
so we have to go out there, feel
it for them, and then come back
and tell them what it felt like.
And that really stuck with me.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Wow.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
That was amazing.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
That is amazing.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yeah.
>> Mandalit del Barco: That is.
I wanted to -- should
we open it?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Sure.
>> Mandalit del Barco: Because
I'm sure there's some folks --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yeah.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
-- that might want to --
anybody want to ask a question?
There's some microphones
up here.
Is there somebody?
I can't see.
It's so bright.
>> I don't have a question.
I just want to say that I felt
it was a privilege to read this
because it felt so much like you
were telling your true story.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Oh, thank you.
>> And I absolutely loved it.
So I'm glad I could
come and hear you today.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, it's kind of
funny because, you know,
I have to find the
things I made up.
Because people ask me, you know,
is there really a kid
named Ookie [phonetic]?
I say no, no, I made him up.
And then I seem like
a genius to them.
They go, wow.
But almost everything
in that book is inspired
by something I saw or heard
about or actually knew.
For example, my favorite
passages in the book are
when the brothers are lying
in bed together talking.
As Juan is sort of
-- Juan -- see --
as Big Angel is sort of dying.
And that was my brother and me.
At that farewell party,
he was very tired,
and they put him in bed.
And then he'd call
me to come back,
get my brother, get my brother.
And when I first went back
there -- he was always a --
not a standoffish man,
but a very contained man;
not a hugger, not a kisser,
never said I love you.
And he said, get in bed.
And I said, what?
He said, come on, get in bed.
And I thought, oh my
-- get in bed with you?
So I was lying there in bed
and we were both looking
at each other like...
[ Laughter ]
And he was tiny.
You know, hadn't been tiny.
And we had these
beautiful conversations.
And I think the conversation
that kicked off the book I put
in the book when he said to me,
hey [speaking Spanish], he said,
I'm lying here thinking
about things.
And I just realized
if you turn 74,
you've only seen
Christmas 73 times.
He said, that's not enough.
And he said, so I
got a question.
I said, what?
And he said, do gringos
kiss each other?
And I said, gringos
You mean, like, in the movies?
He said, no, in families,
do Americanos kiss?
And I said, sure.
[ Laughter ]
I said, yeah, I'm sure -- yeah!
I mean, kiss your mom, right?
And he said, no,
moms don't count.
If you don't kiss your
mom, you go to hell.
[ Laughter ]
I said, oh.
Yes, I've seen dads kiss their
sons, of course, yeah, sure.
So we were just lying
there, and he's looking
at me and looking at me.
And I said, what, you
want me to kiss you?
[ Laughter ]
And he said, no, psh, no...yeah.
So I kissed him on the
forehead, you know.
We're like, that wasn't so
bad, that was OK, that was OK.
And that was the first and
last time I ever kissed him.
So that, I think aside from
just the tumult of the party,
that moment, I think, really
kicked off the book for me.
And I wanted people
to feel it, you know.
I wanted my brother
to be their brother.
Especially perhaps
in this era we're in.
You know, try to do
some subversive work.
[ Laughter ]
Hi.
>> Hola, Luis.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Hola.
>> Hola. You have written and
won awards for being a poet
and an essayist and
fiction and nonfiction,
and now you may be entering in
the TV, Netflix, Hulu universe.
And I always have a
million questions for you.
But the one I really wonder
right now is how you can be
subversive in a new context,
how you make those shifts
from writing poetry to
writing prose to writing memoir
and being the raw
nerve of the universe.
How can you spread that
love and hope in Netflix?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Wow.
Well, I'm a genius, you know.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
Eudora Welty said something
along these lines that out
of love you can write or
speak with sheer fury.
And, you know, I thought either
I'm consumed by the rage I feel
or I try to deal with
love in the work.
So that was a motivating factor.
But also, because I came from,
you know, working-class roots.
I mean, my mother would
be appalled to hear me say
such a thing, but it's true.
I mean, my dad worked
in bowling alleys.
I spent my boyhood in the back
of bowling alleys climbing
around Brunswick pin
tending machines,
running on the catwalks.
I had a little plastic
gun playing James Bond.
I was, like, shooting bad guys
in my mind and they were falling
to be killed by flying
bowling pins
in the...and I watched
my father build things
and I watched my
father repair things.
And I thought, well, I want
to be a writer, so you know,
it may be like being a
carpenter or something, right?
You've got to learn everything.
And I loved all of it.
I loved poems.
I loved songs.
You know, when I realized
Leonard Cohen actually typed
books of poems and
novels, too --
you know, and Jim
Morrison typed out poems,
I started experimenting
with all that.
But I thought one had to,
like a good carpenter,
learn all the tools.
And I did not realize
until college that people,
you know, specialized.
And I thought, you posers.
[ Laughter ]
Especially in the
'70s in San Diego.
The poets, all of them wore
black turtlenecks, you know,
held their cigarettes like this.
[ Laughter ]
That wasn't for me.
So I wanted to write everything.
And I think the other
part of it is, you know,
the flippant answer is if you
imagine the melancholy beauty
of dew on a sunflower --
it's probably a haiku,
not an 800-paged
novel, so it tells you.
And a lot of times, things
tell you what they want to be.
Hummingbird's Daughter started
out to be a history book.
And then I realized at a
certain point that I had --
you can't footnote dreams.
And the dreams were truer than
the actual written histories.
So each book kind of
tells you what it wants,
sooner or later, if
you stick with it.
And that's all I can tell you
because I don't have
any technique.
I just hang on for dear
life, see what happens.
>> Gracias.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you.
Hi.
>> Hi, Luis.
I read the Hummingbird's
Daughter and the Queen
of America, and I
love those two books.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you.
>> And I remember where
your [inaudible] told you
when you were doing your
research that you're a healer
because you write
about all these things.
I would like to know if
you will write any more
about [speaking Spanish].
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
That's a good question.
It was optioned a long time ago
for a film and they ran out --
you know, when they option
a book or a couple of books,
they option them for five
years and then have to re-up.
But I think the issue became
-- so in these two books,
you take her from
birth to death.
So what if it became a
series, how are we supposed
to continue a series
after she died?
And being about the medicine
world and Yaqui mysticism,
I was like, well, we
could write whole books
about her in the afterlife.
And they were like, no.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Aw.
>> But you could
write about her.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Well,
so much material, you know,
came that I couldn't
put in the book.
But there were no
bibliographies about her,
and I've got a gigantic
bibliography
after 25 years working
on that thing.
>> Right.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: So
I've often thought it would be
interesting to go back and
to tell some stories maybe
about my experience
of writing the book.
Because once I entered
into her world,
really crazy things
happened to me.
And, you know, I've been telling
writing students a lot --
because people are doing,
like, PhD things on it,
which I can't believe.
But I tell them, you know, a
lot of the book was designed
as a handbook of initiation.
And there's a lot of
hidden material in that book
about what it was to be
initiated on that path.
And for example, the dreams
in the book are all dreams
that the medicine people
gave me in the series.
And they actually formed kind
of the spine of that narrative.
And the last dream
in the book --
which I won't tell in case
people haven't read it yet --
that came to me, and
I woke up sobbing.
And I woke Cindy up and told
her, my studies are done,
I've got to write it now.
They took me all
the way to the end
of what they wanted me to know.
And that's a really
amazing experience to have.
But it was difficult.
It took a lot of impossible
experiences to write it.
And I don't think I have
the energy or the strength
to enter that world again.
Though again, telling
a narrative
about the experience might
be interesting for readers.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you.
>> Mandalit del Barco: We just
have, like, two minutes left.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Oh, let's make it fast!
Hi.
>> Hi. Just a very
short question, then.
What inspired you to be a
writer in the first place?
And I know, you know, lots
of sons see their fathers
as role models and they follow
them in their profession.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
What inspired me to write?
>> But you in particular,
like, yeah.
Was there a beloved teacher when
you were growing up or...yeah.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh,
it was just love of stories,
you know, love of stories.
And partially, you know, that
little experience I told you
about before of seeing
people that I loved
and worshipped being reduced.
It was like watching
butter melt in a pan.
These people just disappearing
into this clear fluid
in the heat of disdain.
And so I was pretty
sure that, a,
I wanted to be a
Rockstar [laughs], but, b,
I wanted to tell those stories
before they disappeared.
And, you know, like
all poor boys,
I wanted to be rich and famous.
And it took a while to realize
I just wanted to bear witness.
So I think a lot of it came
from madness over books --
still crazy for books -- and
wanting to tell the story
of people who don't get
their story told...I guess,
including me.
>> One quick follow-up.
Like, what gave you the
confidence to write like that
and to know that you should
be a writer and to do it?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Confidence?
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: It's
just more madness, I think.
You know, you just have to
decide you've got to do it.
You've got to do it.
I always tell my students,
you know, I'm a bad professor
for you because I don't
care about your grade.
I don't care if you get a PhD.
I want you to get a
blackbelt in writing.
Because it's a lifeway.
It's my pathway to the sacred.
And so I want you to walk
the road, whatever happens.
And that was just -- you know,
I couldn't -- I couldn't
not do it.
I can't not go to the bookstore.
I can't not get any new Mary
Oliver that comes out, you know?
Or -- right?
Oh, my God.
And so it was that --
just passion, just love.
I always wanted to be a
guitarist, but I had no talent;
and thank God, or I'd be in one
of those dad bands playing
bowling alleys instead
of writing books.
[ Laughter ]
>> Mandalit del Barco: Well,
thank you so much for --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
-- it's wonderful to --
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you.
>> Mandalit del Barco:
[ Applause ]